so i grew up in uh woodhaven queens
jamaica avenue it was on the border of
east new york brooklyn uh they nicknamed
my neighborhood death haven
uh because of all the uh violence
murders uh people ordained uh drugs you
know so it was it was a known
neighborhood we had an area called the
dome it was up in the park it was
something you would see out of kind of
the movies i mean to us it was normal
because we're young kids growing up in
that area
but uh as i'm growing up and i'm going
in that area you can basically go up to
dorman
and uh it was like a five and dime store
of drugs weapons and uh anything that
you wanted to you know buy
they had it up there so you know locally
to jamaica avenue was kennedy airport so
that was used as a hub for all of us to
to uh hijack trucks give me up trucks
and all that swag would end up in our
neighborhood you know sometimes sold in
bulk and then other times salt
individuals will take it up into the
dome and we you know buy it up there or
sell it up there eventually as i got
older become me selling it up there and
putting guys up there at different
locations around the neighborhood
selling drugs with me but to start off
as a kid
i was a young boy that came from a
family that just came from albania my
father was born over in albania
and uh it was
it was a rough country uh
known for being at war since the ottoman
days was no money it was a third world
country suppressed suppressed uh
communism
so when i came into you know when i was
born and my father came into the united
states married my mom uh
people really didn't know what albania
was it wasn't
like saying you're italian or greek or
you know another nationality that people
really knew because the country was so
closed down or locked down you didn't
have that many albanians so i grew up
where my father believed in
violence
as a protection not as a use to hurt
people he wanted to make sure that i
could handle myself
and not get bullied in the streets
where he grew up in uh riventon and
delancey
down in manhattan lower east side was a
tough neighborhood that's the
neighborhood where vito genovese was
born and raised and uh guys like that
where my father became
friends with them but on an outskirts
not uh a gangster he wasn't out there
killing he was a a gambler he was a
street guy he played dice on the street
and stickball and box and he knew all
the gangsters and he got very friendly
with guys like lucky luciano's cousin
blackie charlie luciano same name and i
became one of his partners over the
years so these guys like l greco tough
gangsters uh killers al greco was
was the norm of people that i started uh
seeing as a young boy three or four or
five years old i was on their laps
in a
bronx den card game that my uncle was
partners with luciano and uh al greco
frequent that was basically the strong
arm for him
at that time guys like handsome jack and
these are some of the nicknames and guys
that
were my father's friends and partners in
business and my uncles
so when i'm raised around them
i got a good look at
a diversity of real serious street guys
that
without them saying much
you start understanding are very
powerful you start understanding their
control in the city not just that bronx
uh card game
and so as a kid it was very natural for
me to be
and see violence whether it was in my
streets whether it was around my
father's friends
whether it was in a boxing gym or
whether it was in the basement my father
had us in the basement uh me at three my
brother at four and he'd put gloves on
us and tell us to fight
and you know when you look back people
would say wow your father you know they
they look at him in a hard way i don't i
look at him in a loving way because what
he taught me was to survive the streets
that i ended up living in
you know people say well your father was
nuts for what he taught you he didn't
teach you schooling my father taught me
what he understood was the best way to
survive he did it out of love he didn't
do it out of
uh trying to develop me to be into a
galaxy he tried to develop me to be a
pro ball player and at the same time he
developed me into a killing machine
without realizing what he was doing to
me uh so i i think the aggression
started with me just as a simple thing
riding a tricycle
at three years old and by the time i'm
four i wasn't very
coordinated i i guess at those ages i
was very rough and tumble and my brother
was very
he was actually very graceful so i would
try to stay up with my older brother
which was very difficult because he was
naturally graceful in sports and boxing
and i was very sloppy and i you know if
somebody asked me to do something and go
around
a curve with my bike i'd just go through
it i'd go through the bushes i'd fall
and people would cringe my aunts my
grandmother and they would say johnny
stop riding that bicycle
and instead i just keep getting up
and getting on the bike and i'd be all
bruised up i'd be bleeding everywhere
and my mother would plead with me just
don't ride a bike you don't have to do
what jimmy does your brother just do
your own thing
so i was used to that blood even riding
a bicycle i was used to the pain and i
started embracing it
the more that people said how tough i
was the more i i played up to that even
as a child the more my father put me in
the ring with my brother and he beat me
up the more i wanted to go in the ring
and get beat up and show how tough i was
it wasn't necessarily about winning it
was about showing that i could take it
and as
the years went on
uh i just got more aggressive
and i started running around the streets
and my friends were very very aggressive
guys i come from a neighborhood where
guys were getting locked up at 11 12
years old and all my friends were
killers and they were shooting guys
stabbing guys they were in reformed
schools they were in
juvie uh
spa fed drug rehabs at young ages my
friends were on a david suskind show at
12 years old for violence and drugs uh i
wasn't really
to that level at that time so it was
surprising for people to see
as i kept aging that i was getting more
and more violent and i started slowly
passing my friends as far as uh becoming
that person that people really didn't
think i was but what they didn't see
was the training that went behind it at
three years old my father would have me
down the basement doing five push-ups
at five years old i was down to push
down a basement doing 25 and 30 push-ups
a set
uh at five years old i was running a
couple miles i'd go to the track with my
father and i'd have to follow him while
he was running because he was a boxer
and i started running by 10 years old
i'm running 10 miles myself
and i was in extremely good shape so i
was sitting a boxing ring a lost
battalion hall with some famous fighters
later on was jerry cooney and different
guys like that david sears
who fought michael spanx in the old days
and i look at these guys and these guys
were top-ranked up-and-coming pro
fighters
that i wanted to be just like them i
wanted to be tough like them i wanted to
be an al greco as a gangster so
everybody that i surrounded myself with
were tough guys one way or another and
street guys in my eyes and you have my
baseball coach
who was fat andy ruggiano's sons who
fought andy ruggiano was
a captain the boss of our neighborhood
that was
part of murder rank and lucky luciano
and
albert anastasia was his guy
so albert anastasia straightened out fat
andy ruggiano made him a made guy in
1954 i believe this is my grandfather
figure this is my baseball coach's
father and this is a guy that starts
really
opening my eyes to the next level
of uh becoming a killer
so by
i guess about 12 years old i'm playing
baseball and i'm using that bat to hit a
ball
but then i start using that bat
as favors to different gangsters saying
hey can you go pick up money for me here
or there and it's a slow transition
before you realize you're gonna use that
bat and put it over someone's head when
they don't pay
so as a i believe i was 13
i was working at diggs deli
and uh louis gaddy was a lucasy guy
bookmaker great guy sharp dresser
another good role model as a gangster
for me because he was successful
you know in the street world there's a
lot of bumps but the guys i happened to
be around they're all successful big
money guys tough guys
and sharp guys were you know driving
beautiful cars back in those days with
lincoln and caddy convertibles uh
and i started looking every time i
turned around the next kid's looking at
that baseball player that actor and i'm
looking at that next gangster
and that next gangster is always opening
my eyes to a future in the street not a
petty
street guy but a guy that understood hey
you can get out of this hood
but you have to be intelligent
you can be a killer
or a tough guy but you have to be
intelligent any dummy could go put a bat
across somebody's head
but you got to know when to do it you
know you got to know how to get away
with it and you have to have the balls
to be able to do it alone not with ten
guys and five guys so i started
understanding going with three and four
and five guys that was a cowards move
but if you can go by yourself and do
things you can be very successful in
this life if you have one good friend
you can
basically control the neighborhood but
you need to be very violent you have to
be very slick
and you have to be very loyal to the
guys that you're working for and your
bosses and those days it was it became
fat andy ruggiano
and his children were my
you know my mentors i guess in in the
next level of the mob
so
the problem with anything is when you
get it when you get used to blood when
you get used to pain
when you get used to
a simple thing of putting a bat across
someone's head
and there is no
there is no uh feeling about it because
i'm used to
being hurt i'm used to bleeding i'm used
to having
broken bones
i'm used to having a broken arm and
taking my cast off and playing baseball
because i was trained for this
to ignore the pain
so when i'm hitting somebody else i'm
not i don't think i'm really
understanding at that age
they're not used to this they didn't
sign up for this like i was
brought up as a kid to become a killer
they were just regular people that went
in a little over their head
they weren't training for this they
didn't expect to get a bat across their
head because
they're uh degenerate gamblers or
there's somebody who doesn't pay or
they're a con artist
they always think they're not going to
be the victim
and i was trained to make the next guy
the victim
so
when most people are talking
they really aren't going to take it to
that level you'll hear a guy say well
i'll put a bat across i said it sounds
good in front of a group of people but
they're not really gonna do it and as a
young guy i happen to be around guys
like al greco when he said he's gonna
put a bat across your head he was doing
it
ninety percent of these guys aren't
about that really people don't
understand that they think but you got a
handful of these guys like roy demayo's
of the gang the gangster world or fat
andy with murder inc and albert
anastasia these guys were real gangsters
these are real killers these guys are
guys that were very quiet uh didn't say
much but their reaction and their action
was violence
so as i started adapting to all my
teachers because that's really what they
are they're uh professors
of of a world that uh
especially back in the day was was very
low key and quiet
except for the violent part they taught
me at in those days
to be very aggressive
with your violence and sometimes
they taught me
to do it publicly
so
when i
hurt somebody a lot of times
i did it purposely where crowds would
see and they'd understand uh this face
remember it that's my wallet
this is the way i'm gonna make money
this is the way i'm gonna control this
neighborhood this is the way i'm gonna
control the drug trade and any other
thing i wanna control so when somebody
did something or disrespected me my
organization my guys
uh i was very violent i would be swift
about it i walk into a nightclub
and uh example i walked into a nightclub
called kickers on metropolitan avenue
back in the 80s
and we warned the balances that for now
on these you guys are going to be
unionized there is no more going to work
without going through us if you go to
work on friday
you're going to get hurt you're going to
get shot
and i guess you know on their their
behalf people talk so they didn't take
it serious i guess
you know they didn't they don't
understand the mob world they didn't
understand me they didn't know they
didn't know me that the way i know me
obviously and they didn't think
that i they just thought i was just
another gangster i guess talk and then
given an order and they believed that
their guy would protect them
and i warned the guy
when i shoot you when i hurt you if you
come to work it doesn't matter what your
guy says you're already shot you're
already hurt you're already killed don't
go to work
so i get a phone call and i'm home
sleeping and
i hear they're all at work it's friday
night the music's pumping everybody's
drinking
and i called my buddy
and i said to him uh come pick me up
he said what are you gonna do i said
don't worry just film pick me up
he picks me up it's uh midnight
about that
we get in the car i load up a couple of
guns i got two guns i used to like to
take a revolver always i didn't like
automatics because it automatic jammed
on me once before so i always had uh
that belief that the automatic uh
there could be a problem make sure you
carry two guns i actually carried three
i would carry an automatic so i had the
extra shots i'd carry a revolver and i
would carry a two shot derringer in a
jock strap in case i run out of anything
i have something left that people don't
know i have on me
and uh
we get in the car
we pull up i tell them to circle the
block there's a gas station around the
corner from kickers and and the club
changed names several times
uh they had a couple different names but
the same owners and the people and they
were around gangsters also they were
mobsters
i pull up i tell him just stay in the
parking lot and he's a big guy
tough guy irish guy and he says to me no
no i'm going to come with you guys i
don't need you so when we pull up to the
bar
the one of the head managers is there
and as soon as i see him i says come
here
and he goes john he's trying to talk
and my guy without asking me went to
swing at him but when he went to swing
him i already shot him in the stomach
and so
he looks at me with like a half smile he
goes oh i thought i had him with a right
hand
and you know
people don't understand there's a dry
sense of humor we do because we do it
all the time this is not something that
uh we do once in a while in my case i
did it on a regular basis after i shot
him
one of the bouncers came out to react to
the shooting not realizing he's gonna
get shot
and him i just uh
hip shot i believe i shot him in it in
the right or left it doesn't matter i
hit him in one of his sides of his hip
and then he went down i shot him in the
lake
and then i continued and i went inside
the bar
and i found two other guys that i warned
not to come in one was some sort of
manager and he went to hit me and my guy
went to hit him
and then i shot him
and after i finished with him i looked
for one of the owners who went up the
back and jumped out a side window and
then i caught the fourth guy uh by the
back door and i shot him i think he got
shot up in the chest area somewhere and
then i when he went down i shot him
again so i shot the four guys and my guy
started to run out the door and i said
well where you going now the whole
club you can imagine is in disarray
everybody's running out everybody's
screaming the lights come on the dj
music stops
and i put the gun and i pointed at one
of the bartenders i said don't go
nowhere and i said make me a
a drink at that time i was dream vodka
and cranberry and now i switch it up to
martinis but at that time it was vodka
and cranberry and he looked at me like i
was insane and he says relax i said this
has nothing to do with you ain't gonna
shoot you get me to drink and i told my
friend sit down
so he's looking at me he didn't
understand he goes john we're gonna get
pinched let's go i go relax sit down i
says i've got to make a statement here
and i wanted them to know
that i came there
and i'm not worried about anybody not
even law enforcement and i had that
drink and i said okay and i didn't gulp
it i sipped it i stayed we walked out
the door i put the gun back under my
shirt and as we come there
the police are all pulling up and
you got probably 10 police cars there
ambulance fire engines ems everybody's
there and as we're walking out we just
point inside
like the shooters are still inside
nobody did nothing to us we walked we
went around the corner we got in our car
and we went back to our social club in
ozone park
and i reported back
that uh
this was taken care of and i think they
got the message now that the bouncers
work through also they don't work
after that
when i go into club after club
naturally they're all on board so it
always takes for some reason it takes
these guys to understand
they're not in this world and to really
get it when they see the guys are
getting shot when they see
guys are getting killed
when someone comes looking for me for
revenge and we jump in a car
and when we jump in that car when i jump
in that car talking i'm telling guys
when they jump in that car with me
you're the driver you're the backup car
i'm gonna go kill this guy
i'm not just talking so i tell them set
up a car steal a car get me guns and i
put things in motion
and back in those days larry cucarelli
was one of the guys with me he's dead he
died of a heart attack but his family's
around
and uh i said jump in the call with me
he goes jonah go just get me the guns so
we get in the car
and
one of the guys who was looking for me
for another incident he's driving on the
interborough parkway heading towards
brooklyn
i says when we come around the turn it's
a very slick turn
coming from uh woodhaven going into
brooklyn i believe it's the first exit
towards pennsylvania avenue i says get
next to him and i start shooting
and i hit him in the head
he dies a couple weeks later in the
hospital
the reality of
what i do
it doesn't really hit these guys because
they're not still there they're guys
they're friends of mine the guys
involved with me but they're not killers
but when i tell them afterwards where
are we going to go he says let's dump
these guns let's dump this car burner
and i tell you go burn this car you go
dump the guns you know in the ocean and
you guys meet me go where are we going
to meet i says we'll go meet at the
diner we'll go get something to eat
that's the reality for them
and they understand like this is
obviously nothing to me
i'm going to kill i'm going to shoot i'm
going to do whatever i got to do to be
successful on the street
and by the more people that i
make them understand
that i'm on a different level of
violence and i'm willing to put my life
on a different level
and i'm willing to put myself
to kill somebody to be killed
and you put yourself in those dangerous
situations you're also gonna get stabbed
up like i did
you're also going to get a shot like i
did you're also going to be in the
hospital for months like i was and
you're going to have people
that are just as well as you or worse
they're going to try to take your life
back
but that's what you signed up for i was
used to this i knew i was going to go to
the hospital i knew i'd possibly get
killed i knew when someone pointed that
gun at me i was going to go towards them
i wasn't going to go away
and those are the incidents is why i got
shot up or stabbed up or batted myself
because
my father trained me again at three
years old
you're a fighter
you're a killer you're a killing machine
when all these guys are telling you
they're fighters they're killers and
they're shooters
i know there's an instinct like any
other fighter that gets in a ring or an
army vet that goes to war
they know what their job is when they
get there
the guys that are seeing action
understand what we're really facing they
understand that maybe their guts are
going to get torn out
maybe they're going to get shot
in the body in the head maybe it's going
to end right now but you take that
adrenaline and you use it in a positive
way not in a negative way because you're
used to that adrenaline you're used to
that fear factor because we all have
fear but the people that can't handle
that fear it hurts them the people that
can handle that fear and that adrenaline
rush in a positive way take that and
they use it in their benefit
and things kind of slow down for you
when you're in this mode they don't
speed up
they're they're very precise
they're very calculated moves that i'm
making
people on the outside say oh this guy's
berserk no i'm not berserk there's guys
there's friends of mine like angel
costelli that went
half drunk had cocked up to hurt
somebody and he ended up getting killed
he pistol-whipped somebody took the gun
they shot him in the back they shot him
in the head
because
he's not going in a calculated mindset
he's going in a half [ __ ]
mindset so these are the guys that fat
andy ruggiano al greco told me
uh if you want to be that killer if you
want to be that
guy on the street you want to be that
professional
you have to use intelligence behind the
killing you have to use intelligence
behind making money you have to use
the toughness that you have and and the
ability to be able to get hurt and
overcome it or stabbed up a shot with no
fear and you have to do it in a very
smart way in a very calculating way i
started i i was trained for this
and as the years went on and i'm killing
and i'm shooting and i'm bat and i'm
stabbing
it's taking a mental effect on me
something that i really don't realize
because you're in the moment you're like
a ball player that's up with bases
loaded in
in the world series the only difference
is when you're hitting that ball because
i was a baseball player right
i had a scholarship and so when i'm up
i'm used to that training with baseball
and that zone in a concentration and
you're in a zone you can't hear the
crowd
that was me until
everything shuts down
and then you realize
i can't sleep at night
i start seeing somebody's dead bodies
all the violence all the shooting all
the stabbing
starts taking a mental effect on you
and then you end up with i have ptsd
because there's no way you can kill and
shoot and stab the way i did
and not having a mental effect somewhere
although at the time you're blocking it
out
at one point in your life it's gonna
come out at you
so when i put my head on the pillow i
can fall asleep i'll sleep an hour 15
minutes 30 minutes even two hours but
not more than that and then i'm up i'm
down i'm up i'm down
and you have these
uh anxiety attacks you have these
uh
control factors of your temperament when
someone's trying to
needle you a little bit and trying to
get a reaction you're trying to control
what you couldn't really control over
the years
even though you thought you were under
control you were in control on the
incident but overall
you look for this you look
for
the excuse
for the violence you look for the reason
that someone's getting out of line so
you can release
what you want to release
and what you want to release is to tear
these people apart
for whatever wrong they did
or for whatever job you're taking care
of you're back zoned in
but you're not realizing one day that
you're gonna end up like me
and you're gonna end up with therapy for
years
and if you don't end up in therapy for
years you're never gonna help yourself
you never get a moment's piece whether
it's sleeping or whether it's just
getting a burger somewhere
you this is going to be a 24 hour seven
on your mind
and as this
became another level of training for me
not
the violence that i trained for but now
this is
to have some sort of solitude to be able
to enjoy life again to be able to smile
laugh
and
to go back into
having some sort of normal life you have
to retrain yourself
the way i trained myself since i'm three
years old i started training myself now
with meditation working out
therapy
dealing with ptsd
is difficult but i deal with it by
talking to other people that deal with
it
i'm very involved with veterans
that uh friends of mine that were
serious uh
snipers killers uh war heroes
through uh different wars iraq
afghanistan
and these guys uh we talk about
what it feels like to kill we talk about
the guys that are perpetrating a fraud
and we know they are by the way they
talk why they act
those actions how we control ourselves
not to hurt these type of guys
how not to go backwards and kill these
guys
and you know it's another development
stage
uh that it's a it's always a work in
progress it's no different than somebody
who has a drink and a drug problem
you just say to yourself i'm gonna get
through today and tomorrow i'll work out
tomorrow tomorrow but let me just get
through the next 24 hours so you take it
as a day-to-day thing
so when people are
pointing or poking at the bear
you know
what's in you
you know that you can take them out
like this you know that
it's nothing for you to go kill another
guy
or stab up another guy
or track him down
and beat him senseless until uh
you just tear his body apart these are
normal everyday actions of somebody like
myself
and i know there's not a lot of guys
like myself out there and the problem is
when they disrespect or talk to you in a
certain way you got to be able to
control yourself control your ego and
say to yourself if i'm ever going to
change my life and be a better person i
need to work with
therapists and i need to work with
others that feel the same thing i feel
guys that were
real guys like guys like my friend brian
or jd or some of the guys i talked to
stevie uncle steve or guys that i know
were legitimate
killers whether it was legitimate for
the government for armed forces for uh
uh police work
but the guys that actually were out
there uh
doing what i was doing to really
understand it
the frauds we know we can we could see
the way they speak the way they talk and
we know
uh for us it's just a light switch you
go to the wall you turn the light on and
off it's the same with us
you could turn that light on and off
and uh i turned my light off a long time
ago for 10 years now i work with kids
i try to help them uh not to fall into
that trap and don't develop into that
killer i developed into
so
it's a good feeling that's my new
adrenaline rush this is how i control my
past
is by saving other kids lives so they
don't end up dead they don't end up
killing others they don't end up uh
trying to get retribution for some of
the acts of disrespect of guys on the
street and as i work with these kids
it strengthens me further and further to
continue on my path
of saving lives
and giving back and at the same time it
helps
me to uh cure myself of uh
the urges to hurt people kill people
that are
i believe are wrong in me or my family
or friends
and it helps me in my ptsd and as i
continue on the journey
um
hopefully uh i keep saving lives and
this is my my my way of uh
saving myself
and saving others and i became this
johnny
elite not uh the old johnny you know
people ask me on a regular basis do i
regret
uh the things that happened in my life
and
i say you know these things i wish
didn't happen but i don't regret him i
think
saying i regret him is saying that my
life was worthless all these years all i
did was maybe this was my path this was
god's choice for me to go this way so i
could save lives
so
i i can't say that i i really regret him
because because of the life i lived it
gives me
the experience to be able to save these
kids and and i think maybe that's what
it was meant to be it's as simple as
that i was meant for this path
uh
to save kids and save adults from going
down that path maybe i want to believe
that and that's how i get through my my
uh
bad life i mean the violence
but i think it's
it's something that uh the way i deal
with it
and uh
i learned from it my my lesson from from
all this is uh
we're all human
and i think uh as you go through life
you're going to experience
things from an extreme
and you know so
did i learn i learned that violence
doesn't solve anything
i could kill hurt and stab as many
people as i did and the next guy just
thinks he's not going to be the victim
he'll just keep poking at you
and you got to say to yourself
control yourself
don't do what you used to do if you do
you're going to go down that path and
it's not going to just be him you're
going to go after each guy
that
is agitating you instigating you
and
that's not a path of having a good life
you got to look in the mirror and say i
like myself
a lot more than i hate this guy
and the more you like yourself the more
it'll stop you from
going to kill the next guy or hurt the
next guy
and it gives you the uh strength
to say instead of killing this guy
hurting this guy let me save this guy
here instead let me teach this guy a
lesson that i'm learning through life
through uh
hospitals
through murder through morgues
through
the streets that i grew up with and and
turn my life the way i did and don't
turn back to the bad ways again so i
think that the life experience for all
of us uh is
just our journey whatever that may be
and this uh
was my journey
and there's no way to take it back so i
embrace it and try to work with it
and the things that i did that were
horrible i try to pass that along to
young kids so they don't follow that
path
and i end up here where i am today
all right john thank you so much thank
you great talk thanks
you